inmates have a strict hierarchy for sex
offenders with rapists at the top and
the men who have molested small children
at the bottom
they're known as homos in jailhouse
slang even in Fremont there's nothing
lower when a sex offender comes in and
they are a child molester it is going to
be a lot more difficult so they're gonna
be the first ones that your other
inmates try to come out and victimize
the instant they step into the sow house
the other inmates are looking at them
sizing them up trying to determine what
they're in here for if they're going to
be an easy mark and easy victim and see
what they could get from that inmate
yet one inmate on Foose teeny cellblock
is unusually open about committing a sex
crime inmate Mendoza pretty much stays
to himself even though he might not be
the most muscular or the youngest or the
biggest guy around they know him he's
established himself so he stays to
himself stays out of the mix and he
doesn't cause trouble for other inmates
they'll pretty much leave him alone I
guess based on his therapy and just the
way he handles himself and and just the
person that he is he does seem to be
pretty confident about himself
inmate Randal Mendoza was convicted of
sexual assault and received a 16-year
sentence the victim of Mendoza sex crime
was a twelve year old girl she was the
daughter of the woman he lived with who
was seriously ill at the time and over
the next two and a half years or so it
really got bad and during that time her
my stepdaughter her daughter I kind of
allowed her to become my partner so I
was helping around the house because I
was working seven days a week 12 hours a
day and doing the clean cooking and and
during that time I ended up sexually
assaulting her
I knew it was wrong but it's like I
didn't want to do anything but what made
me dangers at the time as I still did
what I didn't want to do even I mean I
knew it was wrong and I couldn't stop
myself I was just so full you know anger
and stress and push to the end and I
wasn't thinking it was total I was I'm
responsible for what I did because I
allowed myself to get in that position
Mendoza only has one year left on his
sentence but he knows his crime will
hang over him for the rest of his life
sex offenders are singled out because
they picked on the most innocent people
there is their crime as the most heinous
my crime scene is even though I wasn't a
two-year-old but people look at that
they look at the age of the victim they
look what actually happened what type of
contactor was if you if you enjoyed it
or even if you brag about it how you
walk about it but for the most part sex
offenders there they just get off on
victim and victimizing people that can't
fight back Mendoza says he's speaking
out so people won't stereotype all sex
offenders but it puts him at risk people
in here really care about they might be
convicts or inmates or offenders but
they all have children I'd be lying if I
said I wasn't nervous about what I'm
taking the time of telling you about but
I feel there's a reason for it
for me to educate people
[Music]
but telling the truth sometimes comes at
a price and Randall Mendoza may have to
pay
[Music]